The Joe Rogan Experience it's
interesting when you see narratives
and that those narratives are not
accurate and you see narratives that get
pushed like uh one we were talking about
earlier today was the Paul Pelosi video
do you see that video
you see the Paul Pelosi the story yes
there's video of it the cops uh they
released the cops body camera footage
and then they also released the security
footage that shows the guy breaking into
the house and then they release the 911
call so you can listen to Pelosi so
there would always there was some
suspicion that he knew the guy
um but I think that's just because
people are suspicious of everything and
there's always like what's really going
on people always do that but uh you
could really clearly hear from the 911
call that there's a crazy person in this
house with a hammer and he's trying to
keep the guy calm and he thought the guy
was pretty calm up until the moment
where the cops came and you see has his
hand on the hammer I mean it's really
[__] up listen to this because it's
kind of crazy let's do it from the
beginning wow but listen watch this
so he goes in his house so here's the
guy
he's got his hand on the hammer good
all right drop the hammer
um hey hey hey hey what is going on
okay it's horrible because you hear him
snore like he's out cold it's really bad
um a crazy person broke into his house
and attacked him I mean that's this is
he see the guy the guy is uh smashing
his uh door with a hammer that's what it
shows up for some reason he pulls up
he's got a backpack and he pulls out a
[__] hammer and just starts slamming
at the door so he breaks into his house
he seems so cool look at him oh he's
crazy he also just got out of jail so
this guy is uh breaking his [__] door
smashing the window
look at this
and he he goes into this
goes into his [__] house and hits him
in the head with a hammer and so there
was all this uh speculation that people
knew him but that's what's fascinating
right that these these narratives like
instead of people going I don't know
what the [__] going on everybody's
like I know what's going on he was doing
this and he knew that guy maybe they
were doing drugs together maybe they
were doing this I mean and it escalates
like yeah I think it can start that's a
fascinating thing to me is like a random
Anonymous person on the internet
can even just ask a question did they
know each other yeah and that somehow
starts to build up it doesn't matter the
story starts to build up to where
somebody swoops in and answers that
question it's all like Anonymous people
and then somehow they can escalate and
become viral they're supposed to be
scared of the people they're not
supposed to be making the people scared
the government's literally supposed to
be people like you working for you to
make everything better for you it's not
supposed to be like you buy a [__]
house like Paul Pelosi worth you know
millions of dollars in some crazy how
does he not have security that's what
they're worth hundreds of millions of
dollars they swindled the American
public from how do they not have
security
I mean if you got that kind of cash and
everybody knows you got a lot of it
maybe from trading in a way that like
you might have known some stuff before
you made these trades I mean you might
have you might have some inside
information
yeah but there's probably much richer
people to to Target do you know that
there are more successful at trading
than Warren Buffett and George Soros
are they yes
Google that make sure I'm not spreading
more misinformation but I read it I read
it I think it was in
I forget what website it was
but they've made an extraordinary
exorbitant amount of money a huge amount
of money and meanwhile he's just like
hanging out in this house with no
security and no gun
and everybody knows where the house is
like kind of crazy that this was the
first time a really nutty person but
that guy like apparently had just gotten
out of jail he was going to be sentenced
and he was he was going away for
something else that's a terrifying video
by the way terrifying everything felt
calm the look in that guy's eyes did not
feel calm when the when the cops showing
the light on him he was making decisions
you could see it in his eyes he was
making rash decisions very quickly what
would you have done with the Hamlet like
what's two hands first of all not one
hand you don't hold on to your [__]
drink more aggressive yeah just hammer
away you gotta grab the [__] hammer
and control it 100 not to control it are
you tripping it 100 if he's if he's
doing this yeah that means he's pulling
if he's pulling you go behind him yeah
he just put a leg behind him and he's on
the ground yeah he's a he's a crazy
homeless guy he's not a Grappler yeah
yeah I mean this is like real obvious
like you don't get the hammer back by
going forward you go this way so if he's
pulling backwards he's just moving he
just go into him but you never let go of
him never let go of the [__] Hammer
you don't hold the Hammer with one hand
either could do a lot of damage a hammer
can kill you easily yeah and he's
holding a drink throw the drink in the
guy's face grab the [__] Hammer yeah
where did he get hit because he [__]
head in the head in the head yeah that's
what you you hear him in the video we
cut it off before you get here because
it's disturbing you hear him snore like
people do want to get knocked out but no
the like skull crack or no do you know
oh you hear it yeah you hear it you hear
it in his head
yeah it's bad man it's bad yeah I mean
uh I don't know the extent of his
injuries obviously but he's 100 knocked
unconscious there you could see him out
you hear it hit him you see him go down
I mean unless the whole thing's a sigh
up and that's why you don't see the
handle you don't see the hammer hit him
yeah you know it's like maybe it's to
make us feel sympathetic for them you
know look at them they're getting broke
who so they stole a little money they
don't deserve a hammer to the Head yeah
thank God it wasn't Nancy imagine that
guy did it to Nancy
because he would have if that guy had
gotten into that house and she was there
instead of him and the cops came when
she was there he would have killed her
with that [__] Hammer man
and maybe she would have reacted in a
different way than her husband her
husband was trying to calm the guy down
seemed like if you listen to the 911
call then the 9-1-1 call he's he's
having this conversation with the lady
on the phone trying to be calm about
getting cops to his house when the lady
was like saying I guess you're okay then
he's like no no no I'm not okay like hey
like there's like an exchange where
she's not sure what he's because he's
not like outright saying I'm in danger
send police a guy's gonna kill me he's
not he's trying to keep the the guy calm
you got a crazy guy with a hammer in
your [__] house that's what happened
but San Francisco is [__] overrun
with crazy people man the streets are
filled with fentanyl addicts you got
people that are dying on the streets of
overdoses every day it's a [__]
disaster there well I'm just in some
sense glad that there's video of this to
where we know it's a crazy person versus
like that kind of suffocates some of the
computer theories yeah some of which
like Elon started he apologized for it
yeah he retweeted something right about
that this was she was a gay lover or
something like that yeah no that that
guy was a crazy person I mean I don't
know whether or not he knew him
beforehand or had any interactions with
him beforehand but the the look in his
eyes when the cop says you you want to
put down the hammer he's like nope it's
terrifying when he says Nope like that
like he had there was a [__] there's
a wire loose in that guy's head 100 he
just cracks him in the head with a
[__] hammer
I'm gonna have to get a John donaheer
breakdown of how to defending us hammers
I that was not in my uh Suite of things
to consider control of the hammer is
very important
yeah because uh yeah right because it's
a leverage arm you want to control the
hammer you have to understand the length
of the hammer you're dealing with yeah
the size the weight the weight size
distribution is why it's important to
have grip strength yeah
he's gonna work on Hammer defense yeah